all right welcome everyone to basically
the announcement of Tesla energy alright
so what I'm gonna talk about tonight is
about a fundamental transformation of
how the world works about how energy is
livid in across earth this is how it is
today it's pretty bad so that sucks
exactly yeah I just want to be clear cuz
sometimes for people like confused about
it this is real ok it this is actually
how most you know most power of the
world is is generated with with fossil
fuels and if you look at the the curve
that's a famous curve the Keeling curve
which shows the the growth in co2
concentration in the atmosphere and
every year it ratchets up it gets higher
and higher and if we do nothing that's
how that's what where it's headed to
Tunick two levels that we don't even see
in the fossil record so this is
well I think we we collectively should
do something about this and and not not
try to win the Darwin Award the for us
and a lot of other creatures too didn't
so but the way the grid works today is
there's you've got coal you've got
natural gas nuclear hydro and wind and
solar but not not enough wind and solar
obviously so that's that's the sort of
the grid typically in most countries and
then you'll know something which is that
the there's a quite a big difference in
peak to trough usage so the peak usage
is typically at least twice the the
trough usage so please bear that in mind
and a reference that again later in the
presentation that that's an important
point
so what we're talk about is the solution
actually think it's really a fairly
obvious solution of it is something that
we need to do and the solution is in two
parts part one the Sun we we have we
have this this handy fusion reactor in
the sky called the Sun okay you don't
have to do anything it just works shows
up every day and produces ridiculous
amounts of power okay but now a lot of
people aren't clear on how much surface
area is needed to generate enough power
to to completely get the United States
off of fossil fuels
I'm repeal really most people have no
idea they think that it must be so huge
amount of area like maybe you need these
satellites in space and like six base
solar power if anyone should be in favor
of space solar power should be me um
but but but this is completely
unnecessary because actually very little
land is needed to try to to power to get
rid of all fossil fuel electricity
generation in the United States that
blue square there is that is that is
land area that's needed to transition
the United States to a zero carbon
electricity situation it's really not
much and most of that most of that area
is going to be in rooftops so it's it's
you don't need to disturb land you want
need to find new new areas it's mostly
just gonna be on existing the roofs of
existing homes and buildings so I really
get that that image is an important one
to bear in mind when people are thinking
about solar power like how much will it
take is it gonna take summon or smell no
it's just that blue square okay whose
bark now the obvious problem with solar
power is that the Sun does not shine at
night
I think most people are aware of this so
this problem needs to be solved we need
to store the energy that is generated
during the day so that you can use it at
night and also even during the day the
the energy generation buries there's a
lot more energy generated in the middle
of the day than a dawn or dusk so it's
very important to smooth out that energy
generation and retain enough so that you
can use it at night so now what you may
not have noticed in that earlier slide
where I showed the blue square was that
there was one red pixel okay in in Hindi
blue square was a red pixel now sumed in
so you can see that red pixel that is
the size of the batteries needed to
transition all of the united states to
be sola
with batteries okay it is a very tiny
amount okay one pixel just remember that
one pixel is this is the size of the
batteries needed to we nice to have no
fossil fuel generated electricity this
is this is no room at all
so not a problem for solar or batteries
now the issue with existing batteries is
that they saw okay they're really
horrible they look like that
they're they're expensive they they're
unreliable they're they're sort of
stinky ugly bad in every way very
expensive you have to get some sort of
you know you need to combine multiple
systems there's not one integrated place
you can go and buy a battery that just
works which is what people really want
to buy so we have to you entrecote with
a solution that that's the that's the
missing piece that's the thing that's
needed to have a proper transition to
sustainable energy world so the missing
piece is what we're gonna show you
tonight
all right
this is this is a product we call the
tesla powerwall and if you look back
against that wall you'll see a whole
bunch of them as well in different
colors so you can pick your favorite
color and it looks like a beautiful
sculpture on the wall so it's very
important I want to point out a few
things that that are very important
about this the fact that it's
wall-mounted is is vital because it
means you don't need to have a battery
room so he don't have to have some room
filled with nasty batteries it means
that a normal household can mount this
on on their garage or on the outside
wall of their house and it doesn't take
up any room it's it I mean it's flat
against the wall it it has all of the
integrated safety systems the thermal
controls the DC to DC converter it's
designed to work very well with solar
systems right out of the box and it's it
has it addresses all the needs it's
anything if you if you're thinking about
sort of buying a battery what does this
provide you well it gives you peace of
mind so if there's e if there's a cut in
the utilities you're always gonna have
power particularly if you're a place
that's very cold now you don't have to
worry about being out of power if
there's if there's an ice storm you can
actually go if you want completely off
grid you can take your solar panels
charge the battery packs and that's and
that's all you use so it gives you
safety security it and it gives you a
complete and affordable solution and the
cost this is $3,500
and it's NS designed so you can stack
them on the wall so if you look at the
wall in the back you'll see that there
there you can add there are some that
are paired up so you can have two you
can actually stack up to nine of the
power walls so you have I mean if you
even if you've got a pretty big thing
going on you can have 90 kilowatt hours
this lot and very importantly this is
going to be a great solution for people
in remote parts of the world where
there's no electricity wires or where
there's or where the electricity is
extremely intermittent or extremely
expensive so you can take the tesla
powerwall and it can scale globally and
in fact i think what we'll see is
something similar to what happened with
with the cell phones versus landlines
where the cell phones actually leapfrog
the landlines and there wasn't a need to
put landlines in a lot of countries or
in remote locations so people pull in in
a remote village or an island somewhere
it can take solar panels combine it with
the tesla powerwall
and and never have to worry about it
having electricity lines I think this is
this is gonna be great look you wait you
have electricity lines are not the most
pretty thing in the world so being able
to just have this the solution that just
works wherever you are I think it's
gonna be incredibly helpful to two
people that don't have electricity today
so you can order the powerwall right now
on the Tesla website actually go to
Tesla energy calm and you go order the
the power wall right now
and we're gonna start we're gonna start
shipping in approximately three or four
months and initially the ramp will be
will be slow because these packs will be
made in our Fremont factory and then
next year the ramp will go much much
higher as we transition to the Giga
factory in Nevada so this is a good
solution for four homes and perhaps for
some some small commercial applications
but what about something that scales
much to much much larger levels so for
that we have something else so we have
the power pack
so the Tesla power packet is designed to
scale infinitely so you literally make
this into a one gigawatt hour class
solution you could go
you could go gigawatt class or or or
higher and in fact we already have a one
utility that wants through a 250
megawatt hour installation just using
the power pack and of now I think would
be a good idea this be a good time to
transition the power built the pilot
we're using in the building to being
battery power of course so so let's
let's go to the camera feed to let's go
let's go check out the power meter oh
wow the grid it's actually zero this
entire night has been powered by
batteries of
not only that the batteries were charged
by the solar panels on the roof of this
building so this entire night everything
you're experiencing is stored sunlight
so when I say scalable I really mean
scalable so that we can do gigawatt
class installations with the power fact
it's that the whole system is designed
loosely designed for infinite
scalability so we could power a small
city like Boulder with a gigawatt our
class pack and we can we can keep going
here so let's let's say what I want to
do is explore what what is needed what
what's really needed to transition the
world to sustainable energy is this
actually possible is it something that
is within the ability of humanity to
actually do or is it some insurmountable
super difficult impossible thing it's
not so with 160 million power packs you
can transition the United States ok with
900 million you can transition the world
you can base to make all electricity
generation in the world renewable so oh
and primarily solar which will be so and
then going a little further if if you
want to transition all transport and all
actress generation and all all heating
to renewable you need approximately 2
billion Power Packs now that may seem
like an insane number and I'm very
tempted to do that you know the the
billion thing but
look restrain my hand but in order to to
it's like two billion power packs is
that is that a crazy number is that a
possible number it is not in fact the
number of cars and trucks that we have
on the road is approximately two billion
and every every 20 years approximately
that gets refreshed there's a 100
million new cars and trucks made every
year so the point I want to make is that
this is actually within the power of
humanity to do it we have done things
like this before and so it's it's not
impossible it is is really something
that that we we can do and it impacted
you know it's it's something that
obviously we're starting to do with with
gigafactory wine so yeah so but the way
we're approaching the gigafactory is
really like it's a product so we're not
really thinking about in the traditional
way that people think of as as a factory
like a building with a bunch of sort of
off-the-shelf equipment in it what we're
really designing in the Giga factory is
a giant machine it's actually it's a
really think of like it's like a product
of Tesla we're making this really big
product that doesn't happen to move but
it's really big and and and that's what
we're doing is Giga factory version one
and we're building that in Nevada right
now and they will need to be many Giga
factories in the future and with them
you're at this I don't do an exercise
that this is not something that we think
Tesla's going to do alone we think this
is going to need to be many other
companies building sort of gigafactory
class operations of their own and we
hope they do and the the Tesla policy of
open sourcing patents will continue for
the gigafactory and for the powerpack
and bullies other things
so we want to show people the most
importantly that this this is possible
that if you look at that's the future we
we could have where the curve slowly
rolls over and goes to zero no
incremental co2 that that's that's the
future we need to have and that's that's
something that I and the path that I've
talked about those solar panels in the
and the batteries it's the only part
that I know that can do this and I think
it's something that that it's we must do
and we we can do and that we will do
so so thank thank you all for coming
tonight and I hope you had a great time
thanks